mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
mesdames madame la rapporteur notre
commission d'enquête entend aujourd'hui
Monsieur le Roland Lescure ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie monsieur
le ministre vous êtes bien au fait des
missions et du fonctionnement des
commissions d'enquête puisque vous étiez
précédemment à votre nomination
gouvernement en août 2022 président de
la commission des affaires économiques
de l'Assemblée nationale les enjeux de
souveraineté ne vous sont pas non plus
étrangers puisque vous aviez participé à
votre qualité de députés aux travaux de
la commission d'enquête de l'Assemblée
sur la fusion Alstom Siemens et la
politique industrielle de la France ou
encore à la mission de la formation sur
la gestion de l'épidémie de covid-19 où
on voit que les questions souveraineté
sanitaires pour le coup était de premier
plan
depuis que vous occupez le poste de
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
j'imagine que les dossiers relatifs à
l'industrie pharmaceutique vous ont
beaucoup occupé je pense aux échanges
très tendus autour des dispositions du
PLFSS relatifs à la régulation des prix
du médicament et à la clause de
sauvegarde à la reprise de l'entreprise
car élite fabricant des poches à
perfusion ou encore à la gestion des
pénuries aigus frappant notamment
l'amoxicilline et le paracétamol au
cours de ces derniers mois même si les
pénuries sont une question qui remonte à
une quinzaine d'années et qui pour le
coup ont pris un tour assez critique
cette année
et dont la progression est exponentielle
pour l'instant il nous apparaît
toutefois que l'action du gouvernement
concernant les pénuries et la
souveraineté sanitaire c'est inscrite
dans une logique de réaction plutôt que
d'anticipation mais encore une fois vous
ne pouviez anticiper il y a 15 ans en
tout cas votre gouvernement
particulièrement
pourtant la crise du covid-19 a permis
d'opérer un changement dans les
consciences et de révéler au grand jour
les conséquences dramatiques de 20 ans
de délocalisation pharmaceutique permise
sinon encouragés par les pouvoirs
publics on parle de médicaments ici
c'est le même sujet pour les dispositifs
médicaux vous pourrez donc nous exposer
dans un propos liminaire les mesures
prises par votre ministère et votre
administration pour atténuer ces
pénuries mais surtout pour les prévenir
puisque on s'inscrit aussi dans un temps
qui est tourné vers l'avenir une mission
placée sous l'égide de la première
ministre est chargé d'approfondir la
réflexion en la matière
et ambitionne d'apporter des changements
structurels installé en janvier elle
devait rendre de première conclusion
sous trois mois mais nous attendons vous
pourrez nous dire si elle formulera les
recommandations ou gouvernements d'ici
l'été de sorte qu'elle puisse être prise
en compte dans les laboration du PLFSS
2024 voire du projet de loi de finances
puisque nous ne sommes pas exclusivement
sur du des questions relevant du budget
de la Sécurité sociale peut-être
pourrait vous aussi nous donner
davantage de précision sur les aides
publiques à la réindustrialisation et à
la relocalisation pilotée par votre
ministère nous avons aux auditionné la
DGE il y a quelques semaines mais sommes
loin d'avoir obtenu toutes les réponses
à nos questions concernant le ciblage et
la stratégie de ces aides vous pourrez
je l'espère nous rassurer sur le fait
que les enjeux sanitaires sont bien pris
en compte dans la conception de votre
politique industrielle ce dont certaines
auditions ont pu nous faire douter ou en
tout cas
certaines aides sont pas forcément
accompagnées d'une contractualisation
engagement en matière sanitaire pour
notre pays pour cette décision d'une
durée environ d'une heure et demie ne
vous laisserons tout d'abord la parole
pour un propos général de 10 minutes
puis madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
des questions plus précises je précise
également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13 434 tirer 14 et 47415 du code
pénal je vous invite chacun chacune à
votre tour à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
enlevant la main droite en disant je le
jure monsieur le ministre
merci vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci madame la présidente
Madame la répartteur mesdames les
sénatrices et Mesdames Messieurs
vous l'avez évoqué deux molécules
emblématiques ont fait l'objet de
tension importante cet hiver
l'amoxicilline et le paracétamol qui
font partie des molécules je dirais
malheureusement les plus connus des
Françaises et les Français et ces
tensions mis à jour des pénuries dont
vous avez remarqué vous même dans vos
propos introductifs qu'elle ne date pas
d'hier mais qu'elles étaient
particulièrement tendues dans cette
période post covid je veux être très
clair avec vous mesdames
ces tensions sont absolument
inacceptables et nous devons tout faire
pour que elle ne soit plus évidemment à
l'ordre du jour dans les mois et les
années qui viennent
on est aujourd'hui sur un sujet qui est
un sujet ancien il y a toujours eu en
fait des tensions sur des molécules mais
on a changé de dimension ces dernières
années on a aujourd'hui 9 fois plus de
tension sur les médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs qu'on en avait il
y a moins d'une dizaine d'années on
était à 3 400 par an on est aujourd'hui
dans le registre dominier
et donc de ce fait non seulement je
comprends je respecte mais même je je
trouve extrêmement bienvenu les travaux
de la commission d'enquête il y a déjà
eu des missions d'information dans le
passé à l'Assemblée au Sénat sur ces
sujets là mais je pense qu'on est
vraiment sur un point d'actualité
extrêmement important bon c'est toujours
plus facile je dirais de refaire le
match le lundi après le samedi mais
c'est important quand même que on
profite je dirais vous profitiez mais
nous aussi de notre capacité collective
à analyser ce qui s'est passé et surtout
évidemment se projeter à l'avenir je
vais pas passer trop de temps sur cette
dimension là mais ne reconnaissons quand
même ensemble que ce sujet n'est pas
qu'un sujet franco-français on a des
pénuries et on a eu des pénuries
récentes dans tous les pays qui montre
que ce sujet j'allais dire n'est pas
seulement le nôtre et que je vais pas
passer trop de temps là-dessus mais vous
l'avez évoqué aussi c'est important de
reconnaître que au fond l'industrie
pharmaceutique a été au même titre que
d'autres secteurs industriels une
victime collatérale de la globalisation
un peu galopante on a mis en oeuvre
collectivement depuis une trentaine
d'années singulièrement depuis un peu
plus de 20 ans avec l'entrée de la Chine
dans l'OMC c'est globalisation elle a eu
quand même une phase durée lumineuse il
faut pas oublier que ces 20 dernières
années les taux de mortalité infantiles
la capacité du monde à soigner
l'espérance du devis dans le monde à
monter de manière exceptionnelle et ça
évidemment c'est en partie lié à la
globalisation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique qu'on doit on a eu aussi
des limitations de hausse de prix dans
les médicaments que nous avons eu à
consommer dans les pays occidentaux
grâce à cette mondialisation donc ça si
je dirais c'est pour la face lumineuse
mais la façon ça a été dès le
délocalisation des emplois en moins et
au fond une insuffisante prise en compte
des vulnérabilités dans notre politique
globale
de santé publique ce sera surtout
évidemment mon collègue de la santé
qu'auré l'occasion d'y revenir mais
aussi l'industrialisation et ça c'est de
notre responsabilité
les prises de conscience ne date pas
uniquement de la covid mais elles se
sont magnifiées à l'occasion d'un covid
vous le savez on avait mis en œuvre une
première feuille de route sur les
pénuries mais qui concernait
essentiellement les biomédecines et
cette feuille de route qui devait se
dérouler entre 19 entre 2019 pardon et
2022 a évidemment été pas mal affecté
dans sa mise en oeuvre par la covid mais
clairement la crise de covid a été une
prise de conscience les pénuries
récentes ou les tensions récentes selon
les molécules ont aussi permis
d'accélérer la prise de conscience
collective nous avons agi dans l'urgence
pour limiter les effets de ces tensions
et vous le savez en limitant les
exportations par les grossistes
répartiteurs on a produisant une
meilleure information et un partage
d'informations sur les stocks et autres
l'état réagit confinement pour essayer
de gérer l'urgence nous avons aussi
réagi dans le cadre du plan de relance
en lançant la relocalisation d'un
certain nombre de molécules il y a
aujourd'hui 42 projets qui visent à la
relocalisation qui participent à la
sécurisation de capacité de production
de pratiques actives qui existent depuis
la covid mais ces actions il faut le
reconnaître sont encore insuffisantes la
responsabilité partagée je pense que
vous avez reçu des industriels ici qui
ont reconnu que eux aussi avaient un
rôle à jouer avait sans doute eu une
part de responsabilité dans les tensions
dans les tensions enregistrées et
avaient une
responsabilité notamment dans notre
capacité collective à anticiper à
partager l'information y compris sur les
stocks
à bien articuler les stratégies
nationales avec les stratégies
européennes nous n'avions pas de liste
de produits critiques vous le savez nous
avions nous avons toujours une liste de
6000 références de médicaments dites
l'intérêt thérapeutique majeur avoir une
liste de des références j'allais dire
c'est presque comme pas avoir de liste
il faut qu'on puisse la Serrier la
préciser la concentrer sur quelques
dizaines au maximum quelques centaines
de médicaments sur lequel on doit mettre
le paquet et c'est le travail j'y
reviendrai sans doute dans les réponses
aux questions que nous avons lancé avec
le ministre de la Santé suite aux
tensions examinée cet hiver
retenons quand même que les pénuries
concernent tous les pays avant même la
covid l'OCDE avait fait une étude sur 14
pays qui montraient que tous les pays
avaient fait face à des panneaux et
croissantes qu'on avait des hausses de
60% des pénuries entre 2017 et 2019 les
chiffres ne sont pas actualisés mais
évidemment ils se sont accrus en 2022 ce
qu'on a vécu sur le paracétamol vous le
savez de nombreux autres pays l'ont vécu
cet hiver
nous sommes à un moment clé c'est pour
ça que je pense que cette commission
d'enquête est particulièrement je dirais
adaptée autant dans lequel on est parce
qu'on a je pense une conjonction de cinq
facteurs qui vont rendre notre action
plus ambitieuse plus près de Nantes mais
aussi j'espère plus efficace la crise du
covid évidemment les pénuries de
médicaments emblématiques qui ont rendu
plus que jamais je pense ces tensions je
dirais politiquement et au fond
collectivement il acceptable l'Europe
qui ne jouait quasiment qu'un rôle dans
les politiques médicales du fait de la
covid a aujourd'hui un rôle à jouer et
s'est assumé comme tel je pense qu'on
peut être fier que la France y a
participé de dire que la France y a
participé les achats groupés de vaccins
la mise en place d'une autorité
européenne de préparation de réaction en
cas d'urgence etc etc
le la réindustrialisation du pays vous
savez que nous y sommes extrêmement
attachés elle concerne l'ensemble des
industries elles concernent les
industries vertes elle concerne aussi
les industries de santé qui profitent
des politiques menées par ce
gouvernement pour réindustrer les à la
France baisse des impôts de production
etc dans le projet de loi industriel
verte qui sera présenté au Sénat d'ici
une quinzaine de jours il y a des
dispositions qui visent à accélérer
simplifier les installations
industrielles en France évidemment le
secteur de la santé en profitera
également nous sommes en train de
réinventer le système de régulation des
médicaments via vous y avez fait pardon
références madame la Présidente pendant
votre introduction cette mission lancée
par la première ministre à l'automne ne
vise pas à gérer directement le sujet
des pénuries mais peu y avoir un impact
indirect puisque on va y remettre à plat
le système de régulation des prix et des
volumes vous m'avez interrogé sur le
calendrier on devrait avoir les
conclusions de cette mission d'ici le
mois de juillet même si on y reviendra
sans doute dans nos échanges le prix
n'est pas nécessaire nécessairement la
cause majeure des pénuries on a vraiment
un sujet d'organisation des chaînes de
valeur des chaînes de production de
notre capacité collective à anticiper
c'est un facteur aggravant si vous payez
peu les médicaments produits en France
le risque quand même c'est qu'il soit
produit ailleurs les médicaments ont été
pendant très longtemps la variable
d'ajustement du budget de la Sécurité
sociale les produits innovants sont
financés via des économies sur les
produits matures et c'est bien des
produits matures dont on parle
aujourd'hui quand on parle de tenurie
donc cette mission est extrêmement
importante je vais pas être beaucoup
plus long sachez quand même que nous
souhaitons accélérer que du côté de la
santé le ministre de la Santé aura
l'occasion sans doute de répondre à vos
questions très bientôt mais du côté de
l'industrie aussi nous accélérons les
politiques de réindustrialisation de
relocalisation des produits médicaux
dans le cadre de France 2030 c'est plus
de 7 milliards d'euros
qui sont fléchés vers
l'anticipation pour éviter les pénuries
l'encouragement à la décarbonation à
l'innovation et au fond l'encouragement
à la relocalisation nous sommes en train
de constituer avec le ministre de la
santé une liste de médicaments
stratégiques qui sont à la fois
stratégiques sur le plan sanitaire et
sur le plan industriel historiquement je
dois reconnaître qu'à mon avis les
administrations insuffisamment
travaillées ensemble la santé dans son
couloir l'industrie dans le sien et nous
avons mis en place un certain nombre de
nos collaborations elle ne date pas de
ma nomination mais ces dernières années
pour faire en sorte que la santé
l'industrie travaille davantage
notamment dans la constitution d'une
liste de médicaments stratégiques nous
avons des travaux en cours en
interministériel pour aider au
relocalisations nos mamans notamment
avoir une vision globale pour que dès le
début nous puissions réfléchir au
débouché les sujets de la commande
publique et les débouchés sont
extrêmement importants et au modèle
économique nous souhaitons mettre en
place aussi une nouvelle
contractualisation pardon avec les
industriels avec des contreparties on y
reviendra sans doute aussi pour
sécuriser l'approvisionnement je ne
serai pas plus long madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur je suis évidemment
disponible pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup pour
pour ces propos introductifs et vous
dire que certes il est plus simple de
jouer le match après mais en juillet
2018 il y avait déjà une mission
d'information à laquelle nous avions
participé madame la rapporteur et
moi-même sur les pénuries de médicaments
et d'ailleurs qui avait derrière
entraîné un certain nombre de de
réglementation et
une nouvelle organisation demandée par
le gouvernement de l'époque donc voilà
nous avions anticipé une partie d'image
si je puis m'exprimer ainsi madame la
rapporteur s'il vous plaît
oui malheureusement les recommandations
de ce rapport n'avaient pas été
concrétisée par par le gouvernement de
l'époque alors bon ça aurait peut-être
un peu modifié la donne alors monsieur
le ministre je vais peut-être insister
sur un certain nombre de points
que vous avez abordé dans votre propos
liminaires et puis
ensuite je viendrai peut-être plus
spécialement d'ailleurs sur l'expérience
qu'on a vécu puisqu'on est allé avec
avec la présidente visitée la plateforme
de ces 15 et donc on a pu voir
s'entretien avec l'équipe et avec le
directeur donc ça je le ferai après mais
les deux premières questions qui me qui
me viennent à l'esprit suite à votre
propos introductif c'est que vous avez
dit tout à fait justement et c'était
d'ailleurs souligné par la présidente
que depuis une trentaine d'années il y a
eu une politique de délocalisation qui
s'est opérée pas seulement en France
mais de manière
disons mondial puisque en tout cas au
niveau de l'Europe surtout et
c'était en fait la recherche de pouvoir
maximiser le taux des profits pour les
pour les industries et peut-être en
délocalisant en ayant en vue des
exigences beaucoup moins
importante en termes environnemental et
aussi en termes sociales donc
c'est important de le souligner parce
que en à partir du moment où on décide
de relocaliser il faut avoir en tête
c'est énorme là et récompensés c'est
c'est le respect de ces normes parce que
sinon ça serait un match qui ne serait
pas juste par rapport à des industries
qui ne se préoccuperait pas de
suffisamment de ses normes et puis des
industries qui le feraient donc
moi je je voudrais donc vous poser la
question par rapport à cette donnée là
qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêts à faire au
niveau donc de votre de votre ministère
pour effectivement prendre en compte le
respect de ces données et pouvoir en
fait
identifier notamment les les médicaments
qui sont produits du début à la fin de
la chaîne c'est à dire des produits
actifs jusqu'aux produits finis non pas
en France parce que ça serait un peu
pieux mais au moins au niveau européen
donc ça c'est ma première question ma
deuxième question c'est que en même
temps le gouvernement a des outils et à
des outils à sa disposition et pendant
la crise ces outils n'ont pas été mis en
oeuvre donc pourquoi une telle une telle
inertie je pense à la licence d'office
je pense aussi aux réquisitions il était
possible quand on côté en pénurie en
manque de pouvoir avoir une réquisition
puisque nous avions voté au niveau
parlementaire des mesures d'urgence et
donc le premier ministre avait cette
possibilité là donc bon est-ce que ce
sont des outils qui vous semblent
adaptés et est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
les mettre en œuvre et ma deuxième ma
deuxième question c'est effectivement ce
que vous avez dit le constat d'un
fonctionnement en silo et ça on l'a
vraiment très fortement remarqué durant
nos auditions c'est-à-dire on a quand
même l'impression d'un côté il y a la
politique sanitaire de l'autre côté il y
a la politique industrielle mais ça ne
se parle pas suffisamment au niveau
national d'ailleurs comme au niveau
comme au niveau européen donc
là encore quels sont concrètement les
mesures que vous comptez mettre en place
et à partir du moment où vous avez
souligné que vous êtes extrêmement
attaché ce que nous partageons à la
souveraineté il est important que
les décisions qui sont prises par le
gouvernement ne se fassent pas
uniquement par rapport à la performance
des géants pharmaceutiques mais bien des
besoins en termes de médicaments de la
population évidemment la sécurité
sanitaire donc voilà mes deux grosses
premières questions et puis ensuite
genre
merci merci Madame d'avoir porté merci
madame la Présidente j'entends que les
les travaux parlementaires vous l'avez
dit on a un présidente ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui et qu'il y en a eu
d'autres dans le passé je souhaite quand
même rappeler même si je le répète cette
feuille de route a été particulièrement
bouleversée bousculé par la covid que la
première feuille de route du
gouvernement sur les pénuries date de
2019 pour la période 2019-20 exactement
non mais c'est pour ça donc j'entends
qu'on a peut-être pas mise en oeuvre
toutes les recommandations de la
Commission en question mais un certain
nombre d'entre elles ont été mis en
oeuvre notamment la mise en oeuvre de
cette feuille de route qui concernait
essentiellement les biomédecines il faut
le reconnaître à l'époque qui était et
qui reste d'ailleurs à des enjeux
majeurs et sur lequel on travaille on y
reviendra peut-être dans le cadre des
questions qui étaient l'enjeu majeur de
l'époque où on se disait on est un des
pays les plus innovants du monde et on
va être complètement absent de la
production des des médicaments innovants
[Musique]
moi j'ai noté deux mais plutôt peut-être
même trois questions un de votre part
madame la rapporteur une question
générale sur la politique industrielle
et sa relation avec les commerces
internationales et les normes notamment
environnementales importantes qui
pourraient être plus près de Nantes et
plus pressante en Europe et en France
qu'ailleurs deux sur la mobilisation des
outils d'urgence et trois peut-être sur
notre gouvernance et notre capacité à
travailler ensemble sur la première
je l'ai dit en introduction
ça fait 25 ans qu'on délocalise en se
disant ce sera moins cher ailleurs ce
sera plus efficace et au fond un livre
fameux de 2001 l'avait montré le monde
est plat et donc on fasse de la
production ici ou là tout ça est un peu
indifférent je pense que vous pouvez
reconnaître avec moi que cette stratégie
cette politique même si certains avaient
alerté à son sujet avant que nous soyons
pouvoir c'est bien depuis six ans que
cette stratégie elle a été
inversée et qu'on a mis en place une
stratégie active d'attraction notamment
des capitaux internationaux pour
réindustrialiser la France pas seulement
dans la santé mais aussi dans la santé
la stratégie dite tous France a été
assez largement en début de mandat
précédent moqués Cossé critiqué au fond
on voit bien que depuis six ans on a des
grands groupes internationaux et
notamment dans le secteur de la
pharmacie qui choisissent la France pour
se réinstaller avec un défi majeur quand
même c'est qu'on fait beaucoup de
recherches et d'innovation en France et
pas encore assez productions donc ça ça
fait partie on y reviendra peut-être des
discussions qu'on a avec les industriels
quand ils viennent installer des forces
de production chez nous mais cette
grande tendance à la
désindustrialisation à cette interrompue
depuis six ans on est en train de
l'inverser et moi j'entends d'ailleurs
derrière vos questions et en général
derrière la discussion avec j'ai
l'ensemble des parlementaires un espèce
de consensus national autour de ça
une cause nationale industrialisation
elle est particulièrement juste pour la
santé et pour qu'on y arrive il faut
effectivement qu'on introduise pas des
déficits de concurrence exagérées sur je
dirais des composantes extra-financières
et notamment la composante
environnementale si on n'impose pas à
des produits produits ailleurs
des contraintes similaires à celles
qu'on introduit chez nous on risque de
se retrouver toujours en déficit de
compétitivité on travaille là-dessus on
a travaillé avec la filière d'ailleurs
qui a des objectifs extrêmement
ambitieux de décarbonation des pollution
du processus de production avec des
objectifs qui sont de -30 à -30% par
exemple des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 par rapport à 2015 et
ça c'est des engagements qu'on intègre
dans la politique publique et notamment
dans la subvention dans le cadre de
France 2030 qu'on peut faire à tel ou
tel industrie donc pour
bénéficier de subventions en France
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de France 2030
y compris pour les industries pharmace
il faut des carboner on a aujourd'hui
des exemples très concrets nordvaux
nordiques en Indre-et-Loire qui a
décarboné son processus de production en
passant à la biomasse pour lequel il y a
eu des subventions et pour lequel il y
en aurait pas eu si il n'avait pas eu
cette stratégie de décarbonation on va
beaucoup plus loin dans le cadre du
projet de loi industriel verte qui a été
présenté en commission en conseil des
ministres pardon il y a une quinzaine de
jours qui sera étudiée au Sénat en
séance plénière à partir du 19 juin
parce que là nous souhaitons intégrer de
manière plus explicite dans la commande
publique les facteurs environnementaux
et donc le processus de production et sa
qualité environnementale et notamment
son impact sur le dérèglement climatique
doit être un critère explicite
dans la commande publique et on ajoute à
ça alors ça c'est pas dans le projet de
loi industriel mais c'est déjà le cas et
vous avez cité madame présidente
entreprise carlide dans votre la
production on l'a appliqué dans la
procédure de sauvetage qu'on a mis en
oeuvre dans la procédure de Carline nous
sommes prêts aussi à intégrer dans la
commande publique
des facteurs de capacité
d'approvisionnement si on considère et
c'était le cas pour l'entreprise carlaïn
que la fermeture de l'entreprise peut
obérer de manière durable notre capacité
en l'occurrence à disposer de poches à
perfusion on est prêt à intégrer dans la
commande publique un petit surcoid prix
pour s'assurer qu'on continue pour
simplifier à bénéficier de poche à
perfusion et ça va me permettre du coup
d'enchaîner sur votre troisième question
je reviendrai un deuxième madame la
Présidente que ça on l'a fait en étroite
collaboration avec le ministère de la
Santé et avec les acheteurs publics et
ça il faut reconnaître historiquement ça
se parlait pas beaucoup en partie il
faut le reconnaître parce que le
ministère de la santé était en première
ligne sur les objectifs d'économie qui
lui était affectés et donc c'est vrai
que quand on achetait des poches à
perfusion par exemple c'était le prix et
rien que le prix qui comptait mais là
dans les discussions qu'on a eu avec le
ministre de la Santé et les acheteurs
publics on a intégré le fait que des
poches à perfusion ça pouvait peut-être
coûter un peu plus cher pendant 3 à 4
ans mais si ça permettait de sauver et
de redévelopper un champion français ça
va les coups donc vraiment je
j'insiste sur le fait que on intègre les
enjeux extra-financiers dans notre
politique publique l'environnement et la
souveraineté de manière très explicite y
compris dans le projet de loi industriel
verte que vous aurez à examiner et on
travaille de mieux en mieux et de plus
en plus en train d'administration pour
intégrer ces deux dimensions politiques
industrielles et politiques sanitaires
dans nos dans nos stratégies concernant
votre deuxième question sur les outils
on en a mobilisé un certain nombre et
notamment je le répète on a interdit les
exportations au grossiste répartiteur on
a
on est intervenu directement auprès d'un
certain nombre de producteurs je crois
savoir que dans le cadre de votre
mission vous avez visité l'usine UPSA à
Pau
UPSA a redirigé un million de doses de
paracétamol pour les enfants
dans le cas d'une discussion qu'on a eu
avec eux qui étaient extrêmement claire
et avec y compris des dispositions qui
ont été prises pour
stabiliser le prix du paracétamol pour
les enfants dans les années qui viennent
qui étaient clairement l'objet de la
négociation qu'on a eu avec eux donc on
a fait des choses on n'a pas mobilisé la
licence d'office parce qu'on a considéré
que face à une pénurie globale le risque
évidemment la licence d'office c'est un
peu
bombe atomique quoi si elle vous dites
on reprend le brevet c'est nous qui
allons diriger la production avec un
risque du coup que nos pays partenaires
nous le reprochent de manière forte et à
un moment où le paracétamol était en
dépendance et en besoin un peu partout
en Europe nous avons considéré que ce
type d'armes risquait d'être
contre-productif parce que vous savez du
paracétamol par exemple pour les enfants
on a une bonne partie qui est faite en
Allemagne aujourd'hui donc si on avait
pris la licence d'office en disant UPSA
c'est fini c'est nous qu'allons
diriger votre production et la diriger
en France le risque évidemment c'est que
c'était les concurrents que vous
connaissez qui produisent l'essentiel
quand même du paracétamol pour les
enfants fait en Allemagne nous disent
bah c'est gentil mais du coup vous
n'aurez plus d'exportation en provenance
de l'Allemagne donc ça fait partie des
outils qui sont utilisables mais qu'il
faut manier avec une main tremblante et
on a considéré que c'était pas le bon
moment pour le faire à ce moment-là
et vous avez évoqué aussi les
réquisitions madame ma présidente sont
un peu les mêmes arguments qui nous qui
nous ont qui nous ont induit à
privilégier une négociation parfois
assez ferme avec des producteurs plutôt
que la réquisition des stocks qui aurait
pu aussi avoir le même impact un peu
pervers sur les exportations en
provenance d'autres pays
juste rebondir sur l'acquisition des
stocks ce principe là quand même été
utilisé au moment de la pénurie de
produits à destination de la réanimation
puisqu'il y a une centralisation de
stock de curare j'aurais dû
effectivement madame la Présidente
pardon mentionné que dans un cas
extrêmement tendu puisque c'était mars
avril
sur d'autres sur d'autres produits en
tout cas là ça a été
si vous voulez le sentiment que l'on a
depuis que nous avons fait ces auditions
c'est que il y a besoin en tout cas pour
la puissance publique de se doter de
dispositifs qui peuvent lui permettre un
peu plus d'indépendance et de ne pas
être en dépendance
presque exclusivement avec les
industriels il faut qu'il y ait un
pouvoir d'intervention qui puisse être
mobilisés et ça c'est assez
diffus alors quand nous avons entendu la
dgum elle nous a indiqué que les les
aides à la relocalisation qui ont été
mises en place depuis 2021 vous l'avez
vous l'avez souligné
sont en fait distribués sans qu'il y ait
une grande exigence ou en tout cas avec
une exigence on va dire relative par
rapport au maintien de l'activité en
France ou à l'approvisionnement du
marché français
donc
quelle est la garantie
et quel est le dispositif dont vous vous
dotez pour justement être sûr qu'à
partir du moment où il y a
relocalisation et bien l'entreprise ne
va pas repartir d'ici deux ans trois ans
parce que finalement la rentabilité ne
sera pas suffisante il y a besoin que
vous ayez cette garantie or s'il n'y a
pas de d'exigence particulière de
critères particuliers et bien il y a un
risque qu'il y ait donc ce départ le
crédit pour recherche qui est quand même
un investissement important pour les
pour les finances publiques
quand il est perçu il est perçu sans
qu'il y ait de réel contrepartie par
rapport au choix industriel futur donc
nous sommes sensibles au niveau de la
commission
d'enquête puisque c'est nous sommes en
plus la chambre des collectivités donc
dans nos mandats locaux respectif nous
savons que quand il y a des aides qui
sont donnés par nos collectivités et
bien il y a des critères il y a des
contreparties qui sont demandées on a
l'impression que le gouvernement n'en
pose pas n'en pose pas suffisamment donc
est-ce que là vous avez pris des
décisions et vous avez des mesures
concrètes qui permettent de remédier je
dirais à se défaut et je vais enchaîner
sur ces 15 parce que comme je l'ai dit
nous l'avons
visité
c'est donc une unité de production de
paracétamol sur la plateforme de
Roussillon donc franchement on a vu que
c'est il y a une les moyens sont fédérés
puisque c'est une plateforme donc c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
positif puisque en termes de sécurité
etc donc voilà
c'est une mise de en service qui va se
faire bientôt puisque c'est pardon
donc c'est une mise en qui va se faire
bientôt avec une production à peu près
de 10 000 tonnes de paracétamol par an
donc effectivement c'est le soutien il y
a eu un soutien fort du gouvernement
avec le plan le programme France relance
mais
là encore on a été alerté par le
le président directeur général de ces 15
qui nous a dit que il y avait quand même
une nécessité puisque la production elle
était elle serait durable dans des
conditions environnementales qui
semblent respecter
il fallait là encore que les critères
qui sont donc mis en oeuvre au niveau
environnemental au niveau social avec
visiblement des conditions de travail
très positives nous avons rencontré
l'équipe de direction mais nous avons
aussi rencontré les salariés et les
syndicats et ils parlaient tous de la
même voix donc
est-ce que vous êtes prêts avec vos
collègues européens parce que vous ne
pouvez pas le détour le décider tout
seul mais est-ce que vous êtes prêts
avec vos collègues européens de faire en
sorte que si les entrepreneurs les
entreprises ne respectent pas ses règles
bien finalement elle ne doivent pas
pouvoir vendre sur le marché européen
c'est ce que lui nous a suggéré et c'est
radical mais en tout cas peut-être que
vous avez d'autres idées mais en tout
cas voilà la deuxième chose toujours sur
ces 15 c'est que effectivement vous avez
un peu pointé du doigt mais
l'essentiel des des comment dirais-je de
l'industrie qui a été
délocalisé c'est la chimie
la chimie c'est quand même une industrie
qui est plutôt polluante donc là encore
il faut être prêt parce que souvent les
populations acceptent une relocalisation
mais à condition que ça soit pas
obligatoirement chez eux que ça soit un
peu plus loin donc comment là aussi on
travaille d'abord pour effectivement
faire en sorte que ce soit le moins
polluant possible mais aussi pour
travailler en lien avec avec les les
populations et pour que ça soit que ça
soit ça soit à demi et surtout toujours
sur ces 15 ce qu'il avait souligné aussi
c'est que
il pensait qu'il fallait aller plus vite
et donc anticiper pour qualifier les
usines de production parce que ça
permettait d'anticiper les crises et ne
pas être le dos le dos au mur donc là
aussi est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à
cette à ces différentes mesures est-ce
que vous avez rencontré des
matériel avec qui vous avez pu en parler
qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous pouvez
mettre en place parce que en fait
d'après lui pour les 100 produits
critiques il a il nous a dit que ça
n'était pas cher de relocaliser
spécialement parce que les usines
étaient multiproduites donc il fallait
évidemment avoir un investissement mais
en même temps avoir aussi un engagement
par rapport après à au marché parce
qu'effectivement les industriels ne vont
pas produire s'ils n'ont pas la garantie
d'avoir un marché suffisant mais c'est
vrai que en ce qui concerne la pharmacie
que ce soit en France mais surtout en
Europe il y a le volume
merci pour pour ces questions
importantes
je vais essayer de donner un peu de
d'ordre à mes pensées parce que j'ai
plein de choses qui me sont venues
pendant que vous posiez des questions
donc je vais essayer d'en donner tout ça
mais bon d'abord les aides publiques en
général et leurs conditionnalités c'est
un débat
assez assez présent je voudrais pas
donner l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les
aides publiques sont des chèques en
blanc y compris le crédit à Port
cherchent que vous avez mentionné madame
la Présidente c'est un c'est un crédit
d'impôt extrêmement efficace au sens où
je parlais de tous France tout à l'heure
quand vous voyez un investisseur
international en général il vous en
parle dans sa 2 ou 3e phrase qui est
extrêmement bien perçu parce que il
permet d'avoir des ingénieurs des
chercheurs des docteurs français entre
guillemets et oui ça peut sembler un peu
singing de dire comme ça à bon prix la
compétitivité de la recherche et
d'innovation française aujourd'hui dans
le monde elle est exceptionnelle et
c'est grâce au crédit un peu recherche
qu'on le doit donc j'entends certains
jusque le crédit d'impôt recherche est
insuffisamment conditionné à d'autres
critères mais moi je serai extrêmement
réservé sur notre capacité à multiplier
les objectifs et à les concentrer sur un
instrument le crédit importe recherche
ise à financer des activités de
recherche et développement en France y
compris de la part de groupe français
évidemment mais aussi de groupes
internationaux qui s'installe en France
et ils marchent il fait partie des
facteurs d'attractivité importants il
fait partie des raisons y compris dans
le secteur de la pharmaceutique pour
pour lesquels on a Pfizer qui a annoncé
500 millions d'investissements au
dernier souffrance après en avoir
annoncé 500 autres millions il y a un an
pour installer des laboratoires de
recherche et développement en France on
a
introduit et on est en train pardon
d'introduire des contreparties malgré
tout à d'autres êtres qui sont
aujourd'hui donnés aux industriels
typiquement dans le cadre du piec donc
les dispositifs d'aide européen de
subventions à l'industrie vous savez
qu'il y a un piège je peux pas vous
donner le nom à l'oral mais si vous le
souhaitez on le transmettra par écrit
mais il y a un projet qui n'a pas été
retenu dans le cadre du pied de santé
par la France qui était à
l'instrumentation l'instrumentalisation
pendant la mise en oeuvre concrète de ce
biais et avec une entreprise qui
souhaitait s'installer en France parce
que nous avons considéré que les
garanties d'industrialisation sur sol
français n'étaient pas suffisante donc
c'était un projet ambitieux de recherche
et développement on souhaitait vu
l'ampleur des subventions qui soient
accompagnées
industriel nous a dit écoutez tant que
j'ai pas fait la recherche je suis pas
sûr de pouvoir produire on a dit mais
dans ce cas là vous n'aurez pas la
subvention donc on est capable
aujourd'hui de le faire d'ores et déjà
dans le cadre de France relance qui
était pourtant un plan de relance qui
bénéficiait de peu de conditionnalités
qui nous a permis en passant de relancer
la France de manière extrêmement
dynamique suite à la covid on avait
quand même pour l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt dit capacités des clauses
d'options d'achat dans les contrat
d'aide de BPI France donc il y avait des
des clauses d'option d'achat et des
clauses donnons des localisations qui
portent uniquement sur la durée pardon
d'exécution du contrat j'entends ce que
vous dites mal à la présidente imaginez
qu'on puisse subventionner une
installation d'usine et que 1 2 ou 3 ans
plus tard l'usine reparte c'est
extrêmement
[Musique]
douloureux je dirais d'imaginer qu'on
puisse en arriver là mais c'est je pense
assez compliqué quand même
de fixer des critères objectifs
de noms délocalisation je vous donne un
exemple concret sur lequel je travaille
tous les jours aujourd'hui quel exemple
de valdune on a un actionnaire chinois
qui achète une forge et une entreprise
de fabrication de route TGV en 2014 il y
a près de 10 ans qui perd avec très peu
d’être public d'ailleurs en passant qui
perd à peu près 10 millions d'euros par
an et qui disant plus tard décide de
repartir je comprends que ça crée
beaucoup des mois je peux vous dire on
travaille tous les jours pour retrouver
pour essayer de trouver un repreneur sur
ce site mais évidemment on peut pas
empêcher le capital de sortir de France
parce que si vous l'empêchez de sortir
il ne reviendra pas donc on est face à
un monde qui reste ouvert avec lequel il
faut vivre avec des relocalisations que
nous souhaitons
privilégier et parfois des
délocalisations avec lesquelles il faut
vivre mon objectif stratégique et c'est
celui qui m'a été donné par le Président
de la République et la première liste
c'est de s'assurer qu'on est un solde
positif qu'on crée plus d'usines en
France qu'on enferme qu'on attire plus
de capital en France qu'ils n'en sort et
pour l'instant cet objectif est respecté
on va continuer à y travailler sur
séquence
moi je pense qu'un bon exemple de ce
qu'on doit pouvoir faire un parce que
même si visiblement le dirigeant de
séquence vous dit que ça coûte pas très
cher il y a quand même pas mal de
subventions au passage donc on aide de
manière très active la relocalisation en
France d'un médicament extrêmement
important le paracétamol mais on le fait
en innovant on va le faire sur un
principe actif produit de manière
innovante en France et en Europe par
rapport à des principes actifs qui sont
produits de manière moins innovante
ailleurs dans le monde donc on fait
monter en gamme la on met l'Europe et la
France sur le devant de la scène de
l'innovation on aide quand même de
manière importante aux producteur donc
je comprends qu'ils disent que c'est
facile ça coûte pas cher faites chez
nous tout va bien se passer je pense que
si on n'avait pas aidé c'est quand ce
serait pas là donc excusez-moi monsieur
le ministre parce que je voudrais pas
qu'il y ait une ambiguïté il a pas parlé
de
de qualité qu'elle allait
sortir etc il disait que s'il y avait
une volonté par rapport à des usines qui
aujourd'hui existent de produits plus
etc ça ne nécessitait pas beaucoup de
réinvestissement parce que les les
usines étaient multiproduits mais il
parlait pas de non parce que si je
voudrais pas que on se méprenne et que
non voilà donc je m'exprime mieux et
comme ça voilà il y a pas d'ambiguïté il
a pas dit que ça que l'usine qui allait
qui était en train de sortir de terre
n'avait pas bénéficié d'aide ni ne
coûtait pas cher pas du tout du tout
sinon
vous arrêtez tout non mais bon donc
effectivement il y a un non mais il y a
un défi d'accroissement de capacité de
l'industrie pharmaceutique en France qui
derrière cache un sujet sur l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur y compris la
fixation des prix on y reviendra
peut-être dans vos questions etc
mais sans vouloir caricaturer ma réponse
si c'était simple on aurait on aurait
déjà fait quand même c'est à dire que
n'oublions pas aujourd'hui que
l'industrie pharmaceutique est aussi une
industrie extrêmement intense en capital
extrêmement intense en recherche et
développement et que
ces grands groupes industriels
aujourd'hui sont effectivement des
grands groupes industriels mondiaux qui
intègrent dans leur localisation la
qualité de la main d'oeuvre la qualité
des procédures je vais revenir la
qualité et la quantité des subventions
et aussi la capacité à être présent sur
des marchés sur lesquels ils ne sont pas
aujourd'hui pour ce qui est de la
question qui consiste à dire il faut
aller plus vite alors nous on travaille
sur
l'accélération des installations
industrielles ça c'est dans le cadre du
projet de industrie verte que vous aurez
examiné et je pense que votre question
portait plutôt sur la presse dire qu'une
fois qu'on a construit l'usine est-ce
qu'en plus on doit se payer un an parce
que c'est en gros ce que ça dure avant
d'être autorisé c'est vrai que cette
question se pose
on a inauguré avec avec
Bruno Luère Bruno Le Maire pardon il y a
quelques jours une usine flambant neuve
de biotechnologie mais qui sera pas
ouverte avant un an parce qu'elle est
prête mais qu'il faut à peu près un an
pour pour faire les autorisations
on travaille là-dessus notamment dans le
cadre
d'un projet commun avec nos amis belges
pour pousser au niveau européen
vous savez qu'au niveau européen on a
poussé ce qu'on appelle le critiquel
rematérial Act donc un acte
réglementaire autour des matériaux
critiques nous souhaitons pousser avec
nos amis belges un critical médecine
actes donc un acte autour des
médicaments critiques qui consisterait
notamment à assurer qu'on soit mieux
orienté au niveau de la production des
médicaments critiques des quelques
dizaines de médicaments sur lequel on a
vraiment un besoin important et dans ce
cadre là on souhaite aussi pouvoir
accélérer le soutien réglementaire et
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle les
Fastrack dans des pistes rapides pour
l'enregistrement des fournisseurs
européens donc on travaille là-dessus
évidemment on savait les procédures
aujourd'hui sont ce qu'elles sont et
donc les autorités européennes et
françaises et américaines parce que vous
savez qu'évidemment ces processus de
production d'avoine aussi et de valider
par la FDA sont assez lourds et
malheureusement on peut pas trop y
échapper je veux pas être trop long mais
vous avez quand même parler madame la
Présidente de l'industrie de la chimie
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup de la
chimie donc la chimie ça pollue la
chemise est sale la chimie on veut tous
en France mais on en veut pas dans le
jardin ça c'est un des défis
d'acceptabilité sur lequel on doit
travailler la première chose c'est que
l'industrie s'engage dans un processus
de décarbonation de dépollution et il
faut reconnaître là-dessus que
l'industrie s'y engage il faut qu'on
puisse mettre en place des règles juste
avec les concurrents donc il faut qu'on
puisse mettre en place ce qu'on appelle
un level playing feel désolé de tous ces
termes anglais mais qui peuvent nous
conduire à obliger les concurrents à
respecter des critères environnementaux
dans leur production
de manière à ce qu'on puisse avoir une
compétition une concurrence juste il
faut aussi qu'on valorise je l'ai déjà
dit dans mon introduction mais je pense
qu'il faut le répéter parce que c'est un
virage stratégique qu'on est en train de
mettre en oeuvre dans le cadre de la
commande publique valoriser les critères
environnementaux nous avons voté puisque
j'étais député à l'époque dans le monde
après précédent l'intégration des
critères environnementaux dans la
commande publique ils sont
insuffisamment
mis en oeuvre et donc il faut vraiment
qu'on qu'on accélère sur tout ça et puis
il faut qu'on puisse c'est une des
questions qu'on se pose dans le cadre de
la mission de régulation des tarifs en
cours peut-être mieux valoriser y
compris dans le prix
les bénéfices environnementaux et les
bénéfices en termes de capacité
d'approvisionnement que peuvent avoir
tel ou tel molécule produit dans
l'Europe plutôt qu'elle que produite
j'espère avoir traité l'ensemble de vos
questions
donc deux questions encore Laurence
Cohen et puis après Patricia
et Madame Paoli alors oui monsieur le
ministre toujours dans la dans la suite
des questions que je vous ai déjà posé
lors de nos auditions nous avons entendu
donc santé publique France et
santé publique France est autorisé par
la loi agir pour fabriquer des
médicaments en cas de menace sanitaire
grave or le gouvernement ne l'a jamais
sollicité en ce sens et elle ne peut
s'auto saisir alors tout à l'heure je
vous donnais un certain nombre de
leviers vous m'avez explicité expliqué
pourquoi
vous ne les aviez pas utilisés mais là
quand même pourquoi ce levier n'a-t-il
pas été utilisé parce que c'est vraiment
très très simple alors que les pénuries
s'aggravent et y compris hors crise hors
crise du covid donc là ma question en
fait c'est
pour qu'il y ait toujours souver partie
de la France il faut que le gouvernement
puisse intervenir bien sûr en cas de
crise hors période de crise et puis
surtout quand on constate une
défaillance des industriels ça me semble
voilà qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure du
paracétamol et vous avez cité notamment
UPSA
en spécifiant qu'il s'était que ces
entreprises c'était engagées à des
livraisons supplémentaires vers la
France mais à ma connaissance passe à
nos filles
donc est-ce que vous avez vous êtes
intervenu pour que qu'il en soit
autrement parce qu'il est pas juste que
effectivement un certain nombre
d'industriels fassent l'effort pas
d'autres d'autant que là en terme d'aide
publique elles sont conséquentes enfin
ma dernière question c'est concernant
les prix
il est souvent dit que les prix des
médicaments matures sont trop faits trop
faibles en France et c'est ce qui
explique expliquerait les pénuries
en tout cas vous l'avez souligné les
pénuries elles ne sont pas seulement en
France elles ont été européennes voir
mondiales et nous avons pu voir
notamment et avoir l'expérience de la
Suisse les antibiotiques croient sont
beaucoup plus coûte plus cher en Suisse
qu'en France ça n'a pas empêché les
pénuries de de d'antibiotiques donc vous
l'avez dit il faut pas les réponses ne
sont pas simples elles sont elles sont
multiples d'ailleurs mais je voudrais
avoir votre votre opinion là-dessus
parce que quand même les laboratoires
ont des aides et surtout est-ce que un
moment donné vous allez envisager pour
les médicaments innovants
qu'il y ait une limite parce que là
actuellement et la présidente l'a dit
dans son propos introductif les prix
s'envolent et de manière je vais dire
hallucinante exorbitante donc est-ce
qu'un moment donné il faut pas fixer un
seuil et non seulement en France mais au
niveau européen
Patricia Schillinger merci
Madame un présidente
pour vous dire vous avez déjà répondu à
ma question monsieur le ministre sœur
cristal meditine Act je crois que c'est
important de travailler ensemble et
avoir une vision et aussi je pense qu'on
ne dit pas assez c'est qu'il faudra du
temps du temps pour qu'on travaille
ensemble et pas s'imaginer que du jour
au lendemain les choses vont changer je
crois que c'est important et nous les
élus on doit aussi aller dans ce sens là
mais parfois il y a des urgences il y a
une question aussi c'est comment
accepter assurer l'acceptabilité de la
relocalisation de la production
particulièrement polluante des molécules
chimiques moi je sais donc j'habite vous
le savez très bien dans un secteur des
trois frontières dans le Haut-Rhin ou à
2 km de chez moi il y a la Suisse
l'Allemagne et nous avons aussi à la
production de certains des usines qui
produisent donc des médicaments et il y
a la chimie ces vaisseaux par nos élus
aujourd'hui les PLU pour les les
élus remettre en cause et réintroduire
sur des territoires des usines qui
seraient polluentes ce serait hors
question je crois qu'on a un travail à
faire dans certains secteurs on est tous
volontaires mais pas chez nous mais chez
l'autre alors on a beau dire bah on veut
nouveau réintroduire nos usines mais à
quelles conditions et comment et il faut
avoir un langage clair là-dessus et moi
je me demande parfois est-ce que la
France est-elle vraiment toujours
attractive en santé pour les
investisseurs étrangers parce qu'il faut
le dire depuis longtemps on dit il y a
CAF faucon on est prêt on est là mais
quels sont les barrages pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'arrive pas est-ce que c'est
l'ultralibéralisme qui est dans le monde
qui est mondial disons je vais là où je
gagne le plus et je peux le plus on a
certainement des réponses mais c'est
aussi d'une politique de PI 40 ans qu'on
a mené sur notre territoire qui fait en
sorte que peut-être on a des blocages à
ce niveau là je vous remercie
voilà et ma Vanina Paoli Caja oui merci
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur ministre merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces précisions
beaucoup des questions que je me posais
ont été adressées j'en ai deux néanmoins
une première qui est plus de l'ordre
d'une réflexion vous avez un peu amorcé
une réponse c'est sur la nécessaire
approche mais qui qui concerne le sujet
dont il est question à présent mais qui
je pense concerne plus généralement le
sujet de de l'approche de notre 21e
siècle c'est-à-dire la proche analytique
de la structure d'un prix comme
intégrant en fait de la valeur
c'est-à-dire on l'a soulevé la valeur
environnementale la valeur sociale et à
votre avis quel va être le délai
d'aboutissement de travaux européens sur
ce sujet parce que je pense qu'il est
crucial en fait par rapport à la
problématique que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et la deuxième question par
rapport à la quarantaine de médicaments
stratégiques que vous avez pré-identifié
les projets qu'on a soutenus via le plan
de relance vont-ils nous permettre de de
sécuriser notre approvisionnement sur
ces médicaments stratégiques qui ont été
pré-identifiés et si oui est-ce qu'on a
une idée un peu du taux de couverture
c'est du pourcentage de sécurisation que
ça va nous permettre
merci merci à toutes les trois du coup
madame la Présidente
sanofia aussi fait des efforts j'ai
situe ça en passant parce que vous je
sais que vous y étiez et que j'ai été
moi-même il y a quelques semaines
sanofia a augmenté sa production c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas ils n'ont pas
augmenté la part de la production qui
elle-même était dirigée vers la France
mais il faut reconnaître qu'ils ont
augmenté la production ils sont passés
en 3,8 ils ont augmenté la cadence donc
je pense que tous les industriels ont
fait un effort
je voudrais quand même dire que ça
n'enlève en rien une certaine forme de
responsabilité qui est pas facile mais
qui est d'une responsabilité
d'anticipation vous le savez la
volatilité de la consommation de
paracétamol et notamment le partage
entre la ville et l'hôpital a été
extrêmement volatile du fait de la covid
pour simplifier en 2020 2021 on n'a pas
consommé de paracétamol à la maison ou
beaucoup moins puisqu'on était moins
malade mais en revanche beaucoup plus à
l'hôpital parce que c'était l'acte le
covid était est traitée était traitée et
puis d'un seul coup on est sorti de la
covid on s'est retrouvé avec des bons
curlites des angines des grippes et tout
le tralala et on s'est retrouvé avoir
besoin de plus de paracétamol encore
sans doute qu'on en avait besoin avant
la covid et on en avait moins donc il y
a je suis assez sévère sur la capacité
collective de l'industrie pharmaceutique
au niveau mondial parce que tout ça
s'est produit partout à anticiper ce
genre de choses
on pouvait imaginer que en sortant de la
covid effectivement
on allait porter moins de masques et que
ça allait se traduire par une
accroissement des mais mais je dois
reconnaître quand même que les
producteurs français les deux en
question on fait un effort pour faire
face à la crise en augmentant leur
production et en ce qui concerne UBS ça
je voudrais connaître en redirigeant un
million de dos vers la France
du côté de votre question sur sur la
capacité de l'État à reprendre la main
sur la fabrication
malheureusement je vais je vais enfin je
suis pas sûr que je puisse dire beaucoup
plus que ce que j'ai dit il y a quelques
minutes dans la dans la réponse à votre
question précédente
ce sont des armes je dirais un peu de
destruction massive si l'État et ça
existe et c'est tant mieux il faut
pouvoir le faire et vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente dans le cadre du
curare ça a été fait non pas par la
production mais par la réquisition de
stock mais si vous utilisez ces
prérogatives de manière un peu trop
fréquente à un moment où je le répète en
plus la pénurie est globale vous risquez
de vous faire un certain nombre
d'ennemis dans les autres dans les
autres pays y compris les pays adjacents
donc on pourrait imaginer et c'est pas
facile de faire ce type de choses au
niveau européen
mais si la France toute seule avait
décidé qu'elle allait fabriquer le
paracétamol sur son terrain
je dirais entre décembre et février
dernier je pense qu'on aurait manqué de
paracétamol paradoxalement parce qu'il y
en a une bonne partie pour ce qui est du
paracétamol en tout cas pour les enfants
qui venaient d'Allemagne donc vraiment
je dis pas qu'il faut pas avoir ce type
d'Arsenal mais mais qui font les
utiliser vraiment en dernier recours et
avec une main tremblante
en ce qui concerne l'impact des prix sur
les pénurie je suis assez d'accord avec
vous c'est pas le facteur le plus
important il joue et les industriels ont
dû vous le dire pour les industriels il
joue beaucoup je pense que notre
capacité collective à anticiper à
produire à intégrer les enjeux
environnementaux ça a été dit dans nos
capacités de production ça joue au moins
autant pour autant il y a un sujet de
régulation du prix enfin vous le savez
c'est pas l'objet de votre mission mais
vous avez sans doute l'entendre entendu
un certain nombre de fois dans le cas
des auditions le fait que
on
encadre les prix de manière extrêmement
ferme et que par ailleurs la clause de
sauvegarde fait que malgré des prix
extrêmement encadrés quand les chiffres
d'affaires vont bien au-delà de ce qu'on
avait anticipé on récupère après les
faits une bonne partie au fond des
recettes liées au volume via la clause
de sauvegarde fait qu'on a aujourd'hui
des industriels qui sont contraints dans
le monde entier parce que tout le monde
cherche à économiser mais avec des modes
de régulation en France qui sont
clairement inefficients
le fait qu'un industriel puisse entrer
dans une année en se disant je sais à
peu près combien je vends de votre
produit mais je ne sais pas combien je
vais gagner parce que derrière on va
m'en prendre une partie une fois que
j'aurai fait mes ventes c'est
extrêmement
désastreux d'un point de vue de la
capacité d'un industriel à se projeter
je peux vous dire surtout que quand vous
avez de la gouvernance mondiale qui
regarde l'ensemble des pays mais qui dit
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc en
France auquel on comprend rien qui est
cette hausse de sauvegarde qui fait
qu'une fois qu'on a gagné de l'argent
vous le reprend après donc il faut qu'on
il faut qu'on mette ça là et c'est
vraiment l'objectif de la mission il n'y
a pas de recette miracle là encore moi
j'appelle ça le Triangle des Bermudes il
faut qu'on soigne les Français c'est
quand même l'objectif majeur il faut
qu'on le fasse à court raisonnable
il faut qu'on le fasse en
réindustrialisant et ce triangle
infernal il faut qu'on arrive à trouver
des nouvelles manières de réguler les
prix et les volumes de manière à le
faire de manière plus efficace et
notamment vous l'avez dit dans votre
question en s'interrogeant sur le fait
de savoir s'il faut réguler de la même
manière du paracétamol qui est vendu à 2
euros la boîte et des thérapies
innovantes qui sont vendues à un million
d'euros voire 2 millions d'euros le
traitement
alors évidemment on compare des pommes
et des oranges le 2 millions questions
reflète des coûts d'innovation de
recherche extrêmement fort reflète aussi
des le fait que ce traitement est un
traitement en une fois qui permet
évidemment d'économiser des dépenses à
l'avenir mais en tout cas il y a une
question autour de la régulation du prix
et dans la lettre mission on a demandé
notamment aux experts qui nous qui nous
livrent ces résultats d'intégrer la
différence entre des produits innovants
et des produits immatures dans la dans
nos capacités de
d'encadrement
en ce qui concerne les questions de
madame la sénatrice Sillinger d'abord
vous avez raison on a trois horizons
temporels à gérer evidemment on ne peut
pas gérer que le long terme mais il faut
intégrer le fait que si on souhaite
réindustrialiser et redévelopper une
politique de production de médicaments
matures et innovant sur le sol européen
ça va prendre du temps on a parlé de
séquence séquence c'est un projet
emblématique annoncé il faut le
reconnaître avec une certaine pompe à
Versailles il y a un an on va aligner
l'ensemble des autorités pour aller vite
il a été annoncé en 2022 on aura si tout
se passe bien les premières doses de
poste de principe actif en 2026 donc ça
prend du temps vous avez raison de le
faire la raison enfin ça ne doit pas
nous empêcher de travailler sur le cours
et le moyen terme le court terme c'est
ce qu'on a les bonnes procédures
d'urgence quand on fait face à de la à
de la pénurie et le moyen terme c'est
est-ce qu'on est capable avec les
capacités de production actuelle de
mieux anticiper la demande y compris
avec les industriels vous avez évoqué
les enjeux environnementaux et
d'acceptabilité environnementaux de la
réindustrialisation je l'ai déjà évoqué
tout à l'heure mais c'est extrêmement
important vous rappelez par exemple que
dans le cadre du pied le projet dit euro
API qui va installer des capacités de
production en aura et en Normandie qui
relocalise des molécules matures donc on
est vraiment dans de la localisation je
dirais
traditionnel s'accompagne d'un processus
décarboné sa compagne d'un processus de
production qui va être mieux
environnement 10 ans que ce qu'on fait
par ailleurs je pense que ça ça
participe à la acceptabilité sociale des
citoyens vis-à-vis de ce sujet
vous avez parlé de l'attractivité vous
rappelez quand même que
c'est une stratégie qui date depuis
quelques années déjà de ce gouvernement
et du gouvernement qu'il a précédé le
premier comité stratégique des
industries de santé et date de 2018 le
deuxième de 2021 le président de la
République à cette occasion annoncé une
politique ambitieuse de relocalisation
c'est pas facile parce que les
industriels font face au monde entier
que parfois ils ont tendance à vouloir
négocier mais moi je dois reconnaître
quand même que depuis un an je reçois
régulièrement des industriels de santé
qui souhaitent venir en France plus
aujourd'hui pour la recherche que pour
la production donc c'est vraiment un
défi de les convaincre voire même
parfois en faisant du dandonnant que si
vous voulez nous chercheurs moi j'aime
leur dire essayer nos chercheurs ça les
adoptait essayez aussi nos ouvriers vous
les adopterez également parce qu'ils
sont excellents mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les principalement du
fait du CIR ils viennent pour la
recherche il faut qu'on arrive à les
forcer
à faire de la production de manière à ce
qu'il réalise aussi la production en
France ça marche c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec Pfizer Pfizer il y a un an ils
annoncent 500 millions de recherches
cette année ils annoncent 500 millions
dont 100 millions de productions et je
pense qu'on va qu'on va y arriver madame
la sénatrice Paoli Gaja vous avez raison
le la capacité collective qu'on va avoir
à bien comprendre la formation des prix
est essentiel à la fois
l'impact très fort de l'innovation et de
la recherche qui est quand même le
facteur essentiel mais aussi les autres
facteurs combien ça coûte d'avoir un
processus de production propre combien
ça coûte de produire avec des conditions
sociales meilleures en Europe
qu'ailleurs et il faut le faire au
niveau européen franchement ça va
prendre du temps on vient de découvrir
qu'on peut avoir une politique de santé
européenne et c'est à l'occasion du
covid donc on va le faire mais ça va
prendre du temps et donc on a tendance
il faut pouvoir il faut pouvoir
accélérer nos stratégies nationales vous
avez évoqué la quarantaine de premier
médicament stratégiques identifié on est
en train de finaliser la liste avec avec
notre ministre de la Santé sur lequel
vous pourrez sans doute avoir plus de
détails notamment sur la feuille de
route pénurie qu'on est en train
d'élaborer mais on en aura sans doute un
peu plus voire même un peu beaucoup plus
donc on sera peut-être plutôt sur deux
ou trois cent que sur que sur 40 mais à
ce stade sur les 40 on a
identifié
on a grâce à grâce au plan de relance
donc grâce à France relance constituer
une capacité de production en produits
finis pour certaines formes de 14 des 40
et quelques produits donc on a déjà fait
le boulot je dirais sur un tiers d'entre
eux et sur les principes actifs
séquences notamment sur deux d'entre eux
pour ce qui est des principes actifs
donc il y a encore du travail à faire on
va continuer à le faire mais Pierre
Fabre sur le site de Gaillac c'est quand
évidemment en Isère sont des exemples
concrets du fait que on l'a déjà
commencé à le faire même si évidemment
il faut qu'on continue et qu'on accélère
merci Monsieur le Ministre moi j'ai
quelques questions et Madame la
rapporteur terminera cette audition
par ces questions question remarque et
en réaction à vos interventions
donc on a eu un certain nombre
d'auditions y compris
relevons plutôt du domaine économique et
industriel
c'est du Verbatim pour le CIR si on a
gardé la recherche et laisser partir les
usines voilà donc est-ce que
est-ce que on est prêt à faire un
équivalent de CR pour faire revenir les
usines ou est-ce que le CIR peut être
conditionné à ce que fait un peu la
barda c'est à dire on fait la recherche
et en même temps on s'engage sur l'outil
industriel voilà donc est-ce que est-ce
que ça peut être une évolution possible
dans vos propositions
on nous a confirmé quand même que dans
les êtres d'État la condition de la
destination de la production n'est pas
une condition même en cas de crise même
en cas de crise
donc
et donc c'est quand même un sujet parce
que là on est vraiment dans le cas des
pénuries de médicaments alors autant
peut-être
peut-on se dire qu'on ne ressent du
point de vue de l'industrie un peu moins
l'urgence
de mettre des conditions hors crise mais
dans les situations de pénurie parce que
je rappelle que les pénuries c'est pas
que le paracétamol et l'amoxicilline ce
sont certains anticancéreux dont
certains qui sont absolument vitaux pour
le traitement
démocratie maligne par exemple ce sont
des anti-épileptiques c'est la pilule
l'abortive pour laquelle il n'y a pas de
plan B c'est à dire il y a où il y a pas
s'il y a pas on peut pas donc
on voit bien que tous ces sujets là
méritent en tout cas dans
dans l'accompagnement de la
réindustrialisation de se poser la
question de voilà d'avoir un certain
nombre de d'engagements
vis-à-vis du pays qui accompagne puisque
c'est quand même le cas dans la
destination de de la production
un autre sujet c'est celui de de
1030 et l'agence en innovation santé la
pénurie ne fait pas partie de la feuille
de route de l'IS donc je le précise et
ça nous a bien été confirmés
et donc c'est quand même un sujet parce
que même même l'innovation donc il y a
une anticipation quelque part de prévoir
la biotech dans 30 ans ou dans voilà et
de se dire que là peut-être qu'après les
causes de maintenance qu'on les mêmes
plus tard et donc nous on se retrouvera
nouveau en situation de pénurie on peut
espérer qu'on est réglé à certains
nombre de problèmes dans les
perspectives
[Musique]
euh et tout ça finalement c'est c'est
dans le cadre et pas dans le cadre de
l'Innovis de l'innovation il y a une
forme d'ambiguïté alors que dans les
auditions qu'on a eu cette dimension là
de la chaîne de valeur du médicament la
production de médicaments elle est
importante elle est au mois si
importante que finalement la chimie même
si on voit bien que c'est pour l'instant
le maillon faible mais une fois qu'on va
reconstituer la chaîne chimique on a
tous ces sujets là
à se poser et puis vous interroger sur
la taxe carbone européenne est-ce
qu'elle peut dans ce domaine là
particulier être très stratégiquement
ciblée utilisé pour pouvoir finalement
si ce n'est nous protéger en tout cas à
donner un encouragement ou une envie
supplémentaire d'investir et de
construire dans en France et dans les
pays européens un outil industriel
pour le pour le médicament dans la
mesure où quand même le marché européen
est un très gros marché et que
si
il aimait un certain nombre de réserves
une fois tous les pays unis dans le
modèle économique des grands
laboratoires même mondialisé ça a quand
même un impact important donc on a ce
poids là aussi possible les questions de
Madame ne rapporter
où je vous laisse répondre
merci Madame présidente
est-ce qu'on préfère la recherche sans
usine ou les usines sont la recherche en
tout cas moi je voudrais pas qu'on ait
ni l'un ni l'autre c'est à dire que mais
ça c'est mon c'est mon travers mais je
serai le dernier optimiste de France il
en reste qu'un je préfère toujours voir
le verre à moitié plein que le verre à
moitié vide on est extrêmement attractif
sur la recherche et l'innovation il faut
qu'on aille plus loin sur la production
on fait notamment avec le PGL industrie
verte donc je vous engage vraiment soit
dans le cadre d'un examen en commission
soit dans le cadre de l'examen de séance
ça vous y intéresser on le fait aussi je
sais que ça fait parfois un peu râlé au
Sénat en baissant les impôts de
production donc on va continuer à le
faire on aura ce débat dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance on va compenser
évidemment c'est essentiel les recettes
des collectivités locales mais la baisse
des impôts de productions est vise
essentiellement et uniquement à ça
rendre les territoires de France plus
attractif pour les usines et franchement
ça marche on a jamais autant créé
d'usine en France que ces deux dernières
années on crée plus d'usines qu'on en
détruit on a détruit 600 usines en net
dans les 10 ans compressés 2017 on en a
créé 300 depuis 2017 dont 200 entre 21
et 22 il faut qu'on continue pour avoir
je dirais et la recherche et les usines
et le beurre et l'argent du beurre
pour ce qui est de
de du régime d'être d'État effectivement
c'est pas prévu aujourd'hui on a quand
même et nous l'avons voté ensemble ici à
l'Assemblée dans le monde précédent
intégré des critères de capacité
d'approvisionnement dans les appels
d'offres publiques donc ça nous on peut
les intégrer et on l'a fait par exemple
je le répète au niveau de carrelage dans
la réflexion qu'on a mené avec les
acheteurs si on devait aller plus loin
et si on devait modifier le régime net
d'État pourquoi pas pour qu'en cas de
crise on puisse intégrer les conditions
de production ça peut se faire que dans
ce que je disais tout à l'heure le
critique à le médecine actes dont ce
qu'on est en train de travailler avec
nos amis belges et au niveau européen
parce qu'on pourrait clairement pas le
faire au niveau français donc lançons
cette réflexion ça prendra là encore
comme toujours en Europe un peu de temps
mais ça vaut peut-être le coup de se
poser la question en tout cas au niveau
européen je pense que ça peut avoir du
sens l'agence innovation santé c'est
vrai qu'elle n'a pas directement
explicitement la mission de lutter
contre les pénuries dans ces objectifs
l'agence innovation santé moi je trouve
ça exceptionnel et je pense que vous
l'avez auditionné
on a une dirigeante qui n'est tout
autant c'est 15 et P
donc c'est vrai qu'on a souhaité
concentrer l'émission sur sur permettre
aux innovations issues de la recherche
française de croître et c'est important
quand même de rester sur le territoire
il y a que l'objectif il est quand même
d'innover et de produire en France donc
indirectement quand même on aborde le
sujet des pénuries en incitant l'agence
innovation santé à travailler sur la
partie sur la partie localisation des
systèmes de production maintenant
indépendamment de l'IS dans France 2030
on finance la relocalisation quand on a
de l'innovation donc on intègre bien les
sujets d'innovation dans les subventions
publiques de France 2030
et cette innovation elle peut être soit
sur la forme gallienique est-ce qu'on
est en train d'innover dans la forme du
médicament ou évidemment sur le
processus de production et ou sur le
principe actif donc on intègre
l'innovation dans nos processus de
subvention ce n'est pas dans le cadre de
l'agence innovation santé le mécanisme
carbone aux frontières
à ce stade non il va pas nous être très
utile dans la santé concernent
essentiellement les biens intermédiaires
c'est un vrai sujet je pense c'est une
vraie victoire française d'avoir
introduit une taxe carbone qui ne
s'appelle pas comme ça aux frontières de
l'Europe pour essayer d'équilibrer la
compétition entre l'Europe et des pays
moins 10 ans mais à ce stade on le fait
sur les biens intermédiaires et donc il
faudra sans doute réfléchir à son
élargissement c'est pas seulement pour
les médicaments que ça se pose pour les
voitures
si vous taxez l'acier qui vient
d'ailleurs vous risquez de vous
retrouver à moins taxé des véhicules qui
viennent d'ailleurs que des véhicules
fait en France donc on a on a un vrai
défi face à ça dans les conscients et on
travaille de ce point de vue là avec nos
collègues européens mais le macf
malheureusement pour la santé ça va pas
beaucoup nous aider en tout cas pas tout
de suite
j'espère avoir tout prêté je pense que
alors quelques réactions par rapport à
ce que vous avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre alors merci pour avoir précisé
que Sanofi avait effectivement augmenté
sa production elle aurait pu faire comme
ça et cibler sur la France ça aurait été
encore mieux
mais moi je voudrais préciser parce que
quand vous dites par exemple
nous allons continuer à baisser les
impôts de production
et nous allons compenser pour les
collectivités
j'y suis particulièrement attentive mais
comme beaucoup de mes collègues parce
que les collectivités nous alertes en
disant que la compensation elle est pas
le reprenait et puis je voudrais un
petit peu peut-être vous
vous interrogez c'est pas une
provocation mais il y a la clause de
sauvegarde la clause de sauvegarde
quelque part ce sont des impôts de
production mais qui vont directement
dans les poches de l'état donc il y a
deux poids de mesure c'est vous baissez
les impôts de production ce qui prive
les collectivités de ressources mais
vous maintenez la clause de sauvegarde
et je trouve que ça pose la question
qu'on a échangé depuis le début
c'est-à-dire en fait il y a énormément
d'aide qui sont données
au grand labo je parle des grands labos
Big Pharma etc mais le problème c'est ce
sont les conditionnalités qu'il faut
imposer c'est-à-dire il vaut mieux avoir
des conditions des critères dès le
départ en bonne intelligence plutôt
qu'après essayer de récupérer l'argent
en ajoutant des impôts de production ou
tout autre mécanisme moi ça me
semblerait en tout cas tout ce qu'on a
entendu tout ce qu'on est c'est plutôt
ça et ça enfin je vais le dire de cette
façon parce que en fait sa
récompenserait les si je puis dire les
industries vertueuses les plus
vertueuses voilà donc ça c'est ma c'est
ma première remarque et j'aimerais bien
vous entendre là-dessus je suis sûr que
je vais vous entendre j'ai pas de souci
et j'aimerais vous poser une question
parce que sur les les médicaments est-ce
que vous pourriez nous dire combien de
hausse de prix de remboursement de
médicaments stratégique le gouvernement
va autoriser le CEPS pardon à consentir
cette année puisque ça a été annoncé
publiquement et quel médicament seront
concernés parmi les 3000 en situation de
de pénurie ça c'est un élément important
et la toute dernière question
c'est que on a été quand même assez
surprise et surpris par la liste des
médicaments stratégiques parce que a
priori ce serait les médicaments qui
sont
aujourd'hui
en vulnérable c'est-à-dire dont
l'approvisionnement est déjà vulnérable
alors ça nous paraît extrêmement
restrictif parce que la vie nous montre
que ce ne sont pas que ces médicaments
là donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter une précision je vous remercie
par avance merci merci on en a un
porteur alors
je veux pas polémiquer sur la CVE qui
toute façon fera l'objet de longs débat
je n'en doute pas dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
pour l'instant les compensations des
baisses d'un pot de production
non seulement pas été à l'euro près mais
elles ont été à plus que le retrait
c'est-à-dire que la compensation par des
recettes de TVA fait que aujourd'hui
alors il y a peut-être des variations
suivant les communes mais globalement en
tout cas les recettes de baisse d'un pot
de production ont été plus que compensés
je vais pas dire que la baisse des
impôts de production est une est une
formule magique mais ça quand même été
pendant très longtemps reconnu par les
industriels et au fond les investisseurs
français ou étrangers d'ailleurs comme
un vrai déficit de compétitivité par
rapport notamment aux Allemands et qu'on
a réduit ce déficit de compétitivité et
qu'aujourd'hui on envoie quand même
l'impact direct
sur les relocalisations
ce que je reconnais
c'est que ces recettes
elles sont maintenues mais elles étaient
directement liées à l'industrialisation
dans le territoire elles ne le sont plus
donc ça c'est un vrai défi c'est comment
on s'aligne avec les collectivités
locales pour qu'on soit tous intéressés
à réindustrialiser parce que ça a été
dit tout à l'heure le côté je veux bien
unistraliser mais pas chez moi il faut
qu'on lutte contre ça et en général les
maires les élus sont plutôt pour mais il
faut qu'on les aide à convaincre leurs
concitoyens d'être pour aussi et ça
c'est pas facile donc c'est vrai que la
suppression de la CVE est réduit ce lien
entre le nombre d'emplois industriels
pour simplifier et le recettes de la
commune mais en revanche la compensation
elle est à le reprenne donc ça ça fait
partie des des vrais sujets
d'acceptabilité sur qu'elle nous on
travaille au quotidien ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
travaille très bien avec tous les
présidents de région quel que soit leur
couleur politique quand on parle de
réindustrialisation en général on est
d'accord avec la quasi-totalité des élus
nationaux que ce soit des parlementaires
du Sénat ou de l'assemblée et avec une
très large majorité des mères et des
présidents de d'agglomération qui sont
aussi extrêmement alignés alors ça se
fait beaucoup dans des territoires qui
sont historiquement des territoires
industriels donc le vrai sujet c'est ce
qu'on est capable aussi d'aller dans les
nouveaux territoires de conquête pour
l'industrie ou là l'acceptabilité est
pas aussi et pas aussi important
la clause de sauvegarde est un impôt de
production ouais pas tout à fait quand
même il intervient après les faits mais
c'est vrai qu'il a des effets
extrêmement pervers je veux le reconnais
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver autre
chose alors il était moins pervers quand
il
concernait 60 millions d'euros comme en
2017 ou 30 millions d'euros 40 millions
d'euros comme en 2018 mais c'est sûr que
quand il représente 673 millions d'euros
pour l'industrie en 2021 voire même plus
d'un milliard en 2022 là ça commence à
être pervers et imprévisible donc il
faut qu'on travaille dessus c'est ce
qu'on a demandé à nos à nos missionnés
sur la conditionnalité j'ai passé
quelques heures à l'Assemblée là-dessus
sur un débat sur la conditionnalité des
aides je pense qu'il y a des choses sur
lequel on a des véritables je dirais des
accords politiques avec lesquels il faut
pouvoir vivre évidemment débattre
régulièrement mais je voudrais pas
donner l'impression que ce gouvernement
fait des chèques en blanc la plupart des
aides publiques aujourd'hui sont
conditionnés peut-être pas au bon
critère selon vous peut-être selon nous
mais le cier je le répète il est
conditionné à l'innovation et de la
recherche les subventions France 2030
elles sont elles sont conditionnées à un
certain nombre de critères extrêmement
précis d'innovation de décarbonation ou
ou d'autres ou d'autres extrêmement
précis
ce qui est pas conditionné aujourd'hui
c'est les allégements de charge et c'est
vrai que là-dessus avec le groupe
politique dont vous êtes issu madame la
Présidente on a un vrai désaccord de
fond quoi ce qu'il faut conditionner les
allègements de charge à un certain
nombre de nos critères ou pas moi je
considère que les allègements de charge
au fond ils ne font que remettre la
france au niveau de ses concurrents et
de ses voisins en termes de coût du
travail et que ça je dirais c'est la
moindre des choses il faut qu'on le
fasse si on veut que la France continue
à rester compétitive et qu'on continue à
réindustrialiser
du côté des des médicaments stratégiques
j'ai bien vu qu'un qu'une revue avait
publié une liste qui
qu'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas prêt à
endosser on est encore en train de
travailler la liste qui sera sans doute
plus important que les quelques dizaines
de produits qui ont été mentionnés par
cette liste on a aujourd'hui ici mille
vous le savez médicament d'intérêt
thérapeutique on va avoir
au-delà de cette liste un peu attrape
tout une liste plus restreinte de 200 à
300 médicaments essentiels et donc ça
répond je pense à votre question sur le
fait que il faut qu'on embrasse un peu
plus large on aura aussi une soulisse de
médicaments véritablement stratégique
sur lequel il faut qu'on mette le paquet
en termes de suivi renforcé de
priorisation nos efforts de localisation
cette liste ne sera pas publique je ne
souhaite pas que en créant de les mois
on crée aussi de la pénurie c'est un peu
le risque de ce type de communication
donc je pense que c'est des choses qu'on
peut échanger dans le cadre de travaux
parlementaires
confidentiels elle est pas définitive
donc je peux pas vous la donner
aujourd'hui mais en revanche il faut
faire attention évidemment à ce qu'on
appelle des des prophéties parfois un
peu auto-réalisatrices qui conduirait
des médicaments à manquer alors que font
il ne manque pas
j'espère que j'ai répondu à toutes vos
remarques et vos questions
ah oui pardon
communiquer là-dessus ça se fait au cas
par cas dans le cas du processus du CEPS
donc je pense qu'on peut reconnaître
même s'il est parfois un peu laborieux
qu'ils fonctionnent bien au sens où on a
des clauses au sein du PLFSS et
l'article 65 ou dans le règlement du
prix l'article 28 qui permettent de
renégocier des prix quand on fait face à
des véritables contraintes
mais mais on communique pas de manière
systématique et surtout de manière
générale sur les listes de produits
concernés
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre juste
puisqu'on était quand même tout à
l'heure sur
médicament mature médicament innovant
d'après les documents de France
stratégie la moitié de l'innovation est
portée par le public et ça c'est depuis
2009 donc c'est quand même important de
le noter par rapport à l'envol des prix
des produits innovants à partir du
moment où on sait que la moitié est
fournie par le par des aides publiques
il y a quand même un retour à attendre
voilà merci
et c'est vrai et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on
améliore encore d'ailleurs les relations
à la coopération entre le public et le
privé y compris à ce que le public et
lui aussi les dividendes du primaires on
le fait un peu quand même vous avez
entendu parler des bio cluster qui
permettent de formaliser les relations
entre les laboratoires de recherche
publique et les entreprises privées on
est en train dans dans
valider dans homologué 5 merci qui vont
permettre dans des dans des lieux
emblématiques de la recherche française
en région Île-de-France mais aussi
ailleurs dans les territoires de créer
au fond des vrais alliances d'intérêt et
y compris pourquoi pas d'intérêt
financier donc ça il faut que il faut
qu'on l'intègre
pour autant je dirais attention parfois
aux
bonnes idées apparentes qui peuvent se
traduire par des effets pervers à
intégrer la rétinibilité de l'industriel
par exemple dans la fixation du prix du
médicament moi j'y suis j'y suis pas
trop pas trop favorable d'abord parce
que c'est très compliqué de contrôler
les démarches et de ce point de vue là
moi je dois reconnaître que il le savent
j'ai mis pas mal de pression sur les
industriels pour qu'on ait un peu plus
de transparence quand même parce que
vous savez qu'entre les prix faciaux les
préfectifs etc on manque un peu
d'informations mais si vous commencez à
intégrer la rentabilité de
l'Industrielle dans la fixation du prix
d'un médicament vous donner une
incitation au moins efficace
c'est-à-dire que moins vous êtes
rentable plus vous êtes inefficace plus
vos prix seront intéressants et je suis
pas sûr que ce que c'est je suis pas sûr
que ce soit le signal que moi j'ai envie
de donner à l'industrie du médicament et
notamment l'industrie du médicament en
France que je souhaite innovante
conquérante et produisant en France
juste pour réagir à ce que vous venez de
dire ceci dit quand on met un prix très
très bas largement de ça du coup de
production du médicament pour le coup on
va très loin dans ne pas tenir compte de
ces considérations voilà donc il y a
peut-être un équilibre à trouver et
mettre un peu finalement de bon sens
dans cette affaire je vous remercie
beaucoup monsieur le ministre